and today I'm going to talk about semi
Randy unit for learning new networks
with guarantees and this is joint work
with Anouk Kenji and me so we know new
networks a very successful in during
many nonlinear functions and has wide
applications in freedom for computer
vision the natural anguish planted in
and most of the new networks are trained
with simple stochastic way in descent
and however the objective function is a
higher higher in nonlinear hi uncle max
with impossible numerous locum optimal
and seller points so the intriguing
problem we were going to ask is why in
practice HGD works so well for to train
your networks so this is in this program
going to give them the first attempt to
solve this question so we look at one
particular model which is why hidden
their neural net with relew activation
function and the first layer ways i'll
go a coat w case and the secondary ways
are the v case and this function is
premises at photos effect and the sigma
is the rebel activation function we oft
meyer this least squares loss over a
bunch of em data point so the menu
without is that for some nice
configurations of the newer ways the w's
with high probability we can guarantee
that any stationary point will be a
global optimal
so we start by analyzing the structure
of the gradient so the gradient was back
to the first layer whale every K is as
follows and we can so this is for one
particular WK if you stack all the
aquarium together into a long back sir
and we have rewrite them in the matrix
form then that will have this special
matrix where each column corresponds to
one data point and there are M times B
rows where m is the main heating unit
and D is input dimension and this one is
the residual vector where each entry is
the difference between a function
prediction and the target so for simple
location of notation so this is the
concatenated long gradient vector is
equal to the special measures we call B
times the residual vector so an and the
stationary point the gradient will be
zero and somehow if the D matrix is
non-singular then immediately we will
have its our resistor will be zero which
means is a global optimal so in this pot
I'm going to give some conditions under
which this tea would be non-singular and
this is the into the intuition is that
this key inequality where the no of the
r is upper bounded by the norm of the
gradient and also relate to the inverse
of the minimum single variable D that is
if you have small aquarium norm and we
have a lower bound on the smallest
single value would be then the 20 arrow
is upper bounded and great design will
minimize this gradient on
so we can directly try to analyze the
singular value of D matrix which is a
look at the GM matrix which is d
transpose V and it is not know that is
the function of over the way so you
can't difficult to analyze directly so
that's why we introduce an intermediate
variable key where assume the ways our
uniform random and then we take take
expectation of them so this in the media
variable G with no longer function of
the weight a gradual weight then the
spectrum we care about can be decomposed
into parts it's a spectrum of G which
does not depend on the entryways and the
difference between G and GN is crucial
Lewis is the uniform list here
so to pound the first term so note that
G M by n matrix and look at the edges
and tree which consists of inner product
between X I and XJ and the expectation
of these nonlinearities so for radio
activation function this non-linearity
will be an indicator function and we can
calculate this exploitation analytically
which only depends on the angle between
xixj I note that this funky also only
depend on interpreting xixj so it's the
inner product kernel and we can suppose
well assume the data point also
normalized on a unit sphere then we can
rewrite this circle home market
competition where we have this gamma and
gamma u is the spectrum of this kernel
function so basically that barrier is GM
depending on terraces and it is the data
set the number of their point increases
you will concentrate on the section of
the kernel function so for the bounds of
the first thing is that the statue on
the g is ready to the special of the
colonel gamma m and in fact it's the
spectrum of the rebel function is
actually between older one over m or 10
10 10 am-12 ram now let's down the
second term which is different between G
and GN and
it's double bounded by some function of
this o2w which is to call the weight
discrepancy so the weight discrepancy is
defined as follows is the pairwise
similarities between the weight wi n GG
measured by this kernel where this cone
always is related to this rectified
linear function and also minus is
expected quantity so the reason the
intuition behind this is that the
gee-gees is about expected attractive
quality and GN about the actual ways so
the difference is upper bounded by the
quantity which depends on expected
weight and the actual ways
for else to put a two terms together we
have a lower bound on the singular value
of B and for simplified resolve suppose
n which is number of hidden units and B
which is the input dimensions are large
enough and the weight discrepancy lqw is
mona in particular this n is 1 over
gamma gamma m and D is one of our gamma
n and at UW's in this order then we have
a simplified bound that we have ability
this smallest finger value is lower
bounded by minion in number of data
points yeah we don't talk about the true
model yet the discharges this particular
to w8 but not which is not related to
that that you generated monitor so
that's not a concern anything about the
true generated wait the half of it is
over over the better points so with the
half of it is luck you to all the excise
or with a data point hi guys please stop
do random everyone now is a particular
weight is it any particular weight or
not it's not random is that your
optimization problem in our society
Rosalie couple the weights in the room
one yeah that's like that's a point just
later so for now I just let's know any
particular particular w-wait and then if
this is a solution is this tableau has a
low disk remove even this is also hose
in the inner solution okay the kids that
we had once you have this small small
weight discrepancy just like a
certificate of global of the value is
that's what this video yes something
that yeah so you can compute it and so
but yeah so let me pull one moment so so
to get a final arrow if using the same
assumption we can have a power on the
training error which is so on the square
root normal gradient so that means if
you have a small queriendo we have a
small arrow so to talk about the more
about this w business so in most of you
will actually satisfy this low
discriminate but we're not really the
one point that we are not sure yet if
the solution obtained by Granderson or
any other optimization or wooden wedge
we have a small waist discriminant so
that's the still a gap that the future
work double using those class of small
weight discrepancy
well I guess me I mean here's the double
use it for which you prove that you
proved it for each individual sets of
weight in this class this will depend on
your on your own your XL and why all
right yeah so W is so AB define a set
which has small weight discrepancy so
there any W that has small way yes but
we have we're going to see the most of
you will sacrifice more logical see but
we are not sure if that particular point
arrived back when it's time we actually
have smoked iscriviti so the still
further research due to download from
the airport yeah and if you read it yes
so you have more ways than exactly right
always an example so welcome to that I
was about it so the n is the number of
hidden units and v is the input
dimension so the particular issues that
have a requirement you should be in
order square m and mmm so we're actually
in this over franchise vision where n
times P is total number parameters is
slightly bigger than the total number of
data points
and yet to recap that we analyzed the
one hidden air observation as we have
two one hidden air in new network and
ensure that we have progress if the
configuration of the words are nice in
particular have a low wage
discrimination any statement point with
a high probability will be a robot mode
but the key technology qualities that we
don't currently we don't have any
guarantee for any put off for the point
arrived by the optimization algorithm
you actually have a small word decency
so then next we describe the semi-random
unit to address this issue so as we
discussed before that typically comes
from the non-linearity phone but you can
think about a rebel function as a book
two parts where it has none in airport
and it's linear power so for semi
running units we will place this non e
to w is nonlinear for by Randy
projection by our is just the non area
the only depend on random parameter and
we don't optimize that but you only wrap
ultimate any mere assumption so that in
this case the D matrix of the only
conceivable of functions of art but not
be so you will not change as the during
the process forward over optimization so
why does this please respond to random
coin toss it just ran a coin toss right
yes it is just a minute awesome yeah
grandpa eat here
yeah it is are shared by different
indicators yeah so this r is for any
unit for any of any hidden unit I have a
one-armed so if they're MMR's it's like
a random point the bodies they stopped
in six yeah correlators because it went
all the info yet it depends on the input
ice no it's a fake or you fix it at the
beginning and don't you don't optimize
it you don't only off my public make
sure you write right so in this setting
then this D matrix will be well with
high probability satisfied the low wages
goodness is conditioned and this is a
figure of this semi-random unit on the
2d case whereas this shuttle just
directing the shuttle is determined by
our and you can adjust this part early
and here are some property of a semi
rennet unit it sits between the fully
random digit which is rent projection
and from Dan non-linearity which are
used a lot in kota method and between
this fully adjustable unit is in new
networks and so the cycle is compromised
the trade-off between this two kind of a
unit is also meaning the number of
parameters so nonlinear in the input and
according to Bruce manager yang tidak
converts to go optimum with high poverty
and also has Universal approximation
ability next we're going to show some
thermal results I will see this
semi-random features are not as facts
what guru but we can using slightly more
units you met the performance of values
so this digital same result on two data
sets and the blue dots are the railroad
and the red dots are the semi or any
features this green ones are the fully
random pictures that we can see is using
only slightly more unit you can match
the performance relew but compared with
when a future where nature requires many
more units and then another interesting
poverty is the trade-off between width
and depth so give you the same number of
example am sure we can distribute using
more layers or using more prompt with
more units per layer and this
environment shows that if you use full
air architecture and actually chips
lower lower error compared with the two
later and it also won their architecture
so it shows that using 14 runs on your
individual just people also have this
trade-off between width and depth and
usually tabs help
and then some more terms our own real
word that I said for image
classification is for we so effectively
we run convolution and you Lynette and
we would place the matrix multiplication
with the regular version units with tami
reller units and the fully render in it
and we can again see we cited more unit
we can match the performance of relew
whereas in running future even using
many many more units is still a huge gap
between the performance of value and the
conclusion we have analyzed a one hit in
their new network and I just waited wait
more weight discrimination dition any
critical point would have regarded with
a global optimum and the result depends
on the structural decay of this kernel
associated with the rural activation
function and then follow also proposed
that any one of features and this
features are guaranteed to converge to
the global optimal with high poverty and
then also show that you didn't study
more units who can match the problems of
rebel but then for full of any features
who has many many more of unit thanks
[Applause]
so radio is non-smooth so what happens
in points of the gating is not well
defined good question so this difference
points are very small subset from have
the whole point so integral we only you
are going to use the sub gradient to
define that yeah so now at the point 0
we use the defined aquarium to be 0 but
at this point I very small compared with
over the point and if you use to cast
with me 10 genuine mostly detected
window run Jeter point depending on how
exactly we find greatness there might be
a critical point like a local minimum
well however you define degrading it was
non zero but it's still a critical
points too yeah but also although our
radar is not actually but by the
particular point is about neighborhoods
where job so there is more so many
points around the Liverpool who can
control this error so we don't do not I
don't know it will be very sensitive to
that point we more precise you can
justify the dividers the gradient value
at that Chris Kuehl point and then the
or some other values and then the whole
argument you hope the basically
delusional
ok its back
[Applause]